Yeah,
as important as it is to cross
disciplines to transgress boundaries,
whether it's science and art or even
boundaries within science,
it is very tough to do in practice.
It is very tough to interact with
someone who speaks a different language,
who uses different acronyms,
who had tax problems from different
perspectives.
So I think we have to do everything
possible to not only encourage this to
give out more grants that funded,
uh,
funding is of course a huge,
huge problem for interdisciplinary
research.
Um,
but also I think begin to make a
serious,
rigorous case for these kinds of
interactions.
I think too often it's easy to write off
interdisciplinary collaborations is kind
of feel good exercises when I think the
research and literature may clear that
there's often a really,
really,
if not the most productive way of coming
together way of collaborating.
And in a sense we see the most when we
are on the outside of a field looking
in,
when my favorite examples of this is the
website innocentive.com which is,
it's a crowdsourcing website used by
various fortune 100 companies.
So Eli Lilly helped develop it.
But you know,
Pfizer uses it.
Proctor and gamble uses the General
Electric Kraft foods companies with
huge,
huge r and d budgets and the billions of
dollars,
but they do is they post their hardest
scientific problems on this website.
The problems their own scientists can
solve and they catch a reward to it.
So if you can solve a problem for g a
chemistry problem,
say maybe you'll get $1 million,
maybe it will be $50,000 who knows?
But,
but you know,
that's the incentive part of incentive.
Now,
the first surprisingly about [inaudible]
dot com is that it works about anywhere
between 30 to 50% of these problems are
solved within six months.
Some are solved within days of being
posted online.
So I mean,
this is kind of surprising,
I think,
because here problems that these huge
companies can solve and yet some
stranger sitting on his couch in his
pajamas while eating fruit loops is
solving them,
making it look easy.
Now what's most interesting but
incentives,
how these problems get solved.
And this is work by cream and Connie at
Harvard business school,
he is shown that let's say ge posted
chemistry problem online.
Then prom is almost never solved by
another chemist.
Instead it's all biomolecular molecular
biologist by biophysicists,
by someone who knows enough to
understand the terms of the question but
doesn't know so much that they run into
the exact same stumbling blocks as the
chemist back at Ge.
So this is a real testament to the
virtues of outsider thinking and
outsider creativity.
And I think we have to realize that this
is,
this is a real thing that we have to
incorporate in,
you know,
in you know,
in everyday work,
you know,
in the everyday world.
Cause I think we come with this tacit
assumption that if you're struggling
with a really hard problem,
you got to give to the guy who knows the
most to those expert insiders.
But sometimes when it comes to
creativity and innovation,
sometimes knowledge is a blind spot.
Sometimes we can know too much,
sometimes we have our best thoughts when
we're working with someone.
In a different field,
tackling a problem just beyond our area
of expertise.
Um,
so I think that's,
that's a very practical case for
interdisciplinary collaboration.
Okay.